se ieri forse questo è l'ultimo episodio
di scrivere punto io fatemi sapere nei
commenti se ne volete assolutamente un
altro l'idiozia arriverà al limite forse
lo superiamo anche intanto buona visione
ma non è fatto benissimo sto personaggio
che sembra che quando lui ma non ci
credo ma quella sembrava palesemente la
persona che guarda l'orizzonte a 3 col
con la bilancia conserte dietro e pablo
escobar e che guarda nulla ok ok no come
ok ok ok dei bei capelli penso siano e
se è un misto tra un super segnare un
power ranger che sembrano meno dei
legali ed in fase non il dito medio
anche ha colpito ma l'autore pura forma
erano tutti c'è una mappa alberto di una
persona non meno milan ero campione
porta soltanto che mi fermi qui voglio
sul pezzo
ma altre lettere confermi a è sì ho
capito a ripetere lisio c'è la s in
mezzo cioè se in mezzo a tutti i sud
malissimo non ci riguarda cosa che ci
riguarda non fare
la pro sesto 3 giu vai a destra numeri a
parte che l'est è a destra e manca però
una busta allo specchio genio bellezza e
ho fatto un ora prima dai vestiti che
stai facendo un bottone un tamagotchi
che così quella roba che lo stile sandro
sottile vabbè allora con la z lì in
mezzo non conosco nessuna parola con
l'azienda
anche noah regali non capirò mai che
cazzo c'è scritto da dentro fu più che
cazzo è quella roba lì scusa comunque
non scritto tutti è un pazzo pazzo porco
di più vista la zona dal camion
esecuzione o ha sbagliato tutte le
prospettive come quando hai fatto
facciamo che tipo così no no no sta che
in cambio la so se farò disegnato tanto
male per un gioco in cui si basa sui
disegni il problema e dai si capisce ma
si capisce tantissimo sta facendo
quest'uomo dovete concentrarvi sul
camino sul cammino è perché si nuovi
modelli con le marmitte sopra ma tutto
chiaro attenzione ok famiglia ma no ma
adesso mi spiega allora i verdi a lei
chiarissimo
[Risate]
quanto manca la fine di questo supplizio
ah no cosa ok ok
mamma mia certo hai fatto un po troppe
righe nocerino nella stessa riga del 19
doveva essere un 12 quello che hanno
finito di malga panna intestata ma cosa
no ma non è vero legame non è vero ok ok
ma come quanto store che stavamo natale
mi sembra scritto con il re ha visto una
nutria erano finite le renne quelli che
bel cerchio come ti chiami 6 mancini 6 a
anch'io lanfranco tutti quanti a caso
era scrivere chiarissimo dal bello bello
me la moglie lo mette come sfondo del
desktop favola vorrei stampare a merita
ed al posto della foto dei miei genitori
[Risate]
all'ultima ok
l'ultimo round l'ultimo all'ultimo
l'ultimo ultimo l'ultimo è più linee per
favore no è una cella evidente è che la
puglia in negativo impiegati
sì ma come detto viene data una cazzata
mi ha aiutato la cosa che ha detto è
però effettivamente di non sembra
effettivamente quello che è ma cos'è
sembra una gamba staccata da una persona
che cos'è ma ben di dio e non copio però
è quello della taglia quello è una
pallina e questa secondo me va bene
prima attenzione guarda che per
pochissimi punti accettato seconda basta
basta
è questo era a secret of un giorno salta
ovviamente non si può vincere sempre o e
che però mi è piaciuta la giocata poi mi
sono divertito un sacco ragazzi spero vi
siate divertiti anche voi iscrivetevi al
canale spiaggia del tasto mi piace e
come sempre noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video di belle ragazze
[Musica]